[Musique]
non
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture tout de suite le
sommaire pupitre encre cartable d'époque
immersion dans une école du début du 20e
siècle la maison de covilha voisins le
bretonneux accueille une exposition qui
nous fait voyager dans le temps
c'est l'une des personnalités yvelinoise
mise en avant dans le dossier du mois de
tv 78 le danseur professionnel
christophe ouest a fait ses débuts au
sein de la compagnie illicites dance il
est en ce moment sur la scène de l'opéra
bastille à paris si vous cherchez des
idées de sorties à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines petite
sélection à la fin de cette émission
et comme d'habitude il y en a pour tous
les goûts du théâtre de l'humour ou
encore de la musique jusqu'au 18
décembre la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux et le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines vous
propose de replonger en enfance avec une
exposition intitulée au tableau une
histoire des cols au programme de la
nostalgie pour les plus anciens et de la
découverte pour les plus jeunes
[Musique]
à une époque où l'on écrivait ses
devoirs avec de lancre une époque où les
classes n'étaient pas mixtes
durant trois semaines la maison de
covile de voisins-le-bretonneux se
téléporte au début du 20e siècle pour
montrer au public ce qu'était une école
en 1900 la salle dans lequel nous sommes
est typiquement l'école 1900 vous avez
son poil qui est sur la droite plus
l'ensemble des publics qui sont devant
nous et qui représente tout les ages
scolaire avec tellement depuis sept ans
jusqu'à présent pour présenter ces
objets d'époque le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines et la ville
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont noué des
partenariats avec le musée de l'école de
chartres ou encore le musée de
l'éducation du val d'oise à gonesse en
1882 la loi jules ferry rend
l'enseignement obligatoire entre 6 et 13
ans un enseignement pour toutes et tous
qui utilisait parfois d'autres méthodes
pédagogiques vous avez sur le tableau
une morale par exemple où chaque jour
les enfants qui arrivaient lisait la
morale du jour l'instruction civique
était d'actualité
la formation le respect de la patrie
était aussi d'actualité
donc c'est ces thèmes effectivement de
l'époque sont aujourd'hui un peu on peu
disparu au profit effectivement de
l'enfant qui doit apprendre s'épanouir
seule une exposition visible jusqu'au 18
décembre et qui saura réveiller le jeune
écolier qui sommeille en chacun de nous
lutter contre l'antisémitisme à travers
l'art depuis le début du mois de
novembre le théâtre montansier à
versailles seront dans des lycées pour
lire des textes d'albert cohen ou encore
de primo levi et des auteurs touché par
le racisme
plus de 2500 élèves évinois sont
concernés par cette démarche nous avons
assisté à l'une des représentations qui
nous un bien albert cohen publie ses
mots en 1972 il relate une histoire son
histoire celle de ses 10 ans
depuis le 18 novembre samir siad les lie
à des lycéens pour sensibiliser à
l'antisémitisme content de lecture mais
dans tous les sens du terme sterp à la
fois une lecture à voix haute
on fait passer les mots des auteurs mais
aussi une lecture dans le champ d'une
interprétation donc forcément et a
fortiori face à de tels textes on peut
pas rester indifférent
des lectures lancé par le théâtre
montansier une vingtaine de lycées lino
à l'accueil en novembre et en mars le
programme scolaire des lycéens faits qui
sont sensibilisés
avec tout ce qui s'est passé pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale etc il aborde
le sujet avec plus de notion donc c'est
plus facile de diriger
vers eux d'autant que ces textes sont
très porteurs à albert cohen se joint
primo levi qui témoigne de sa survie à
auch une lecture d'une heure suivi d'un
échange entre jeanne et comédien c'était
très émouvant
on voit que certaines personnes peuvent
vraiment se reconnaître dans ce dans le
rôle du petit garçon ça m'a touché parce
qu'on retrouve vraiment le cours de
dents en fait c'est c'est vraiment la
même chose que ce que le prof nous
raconte c'est vraiment une histoire
sincère ça ça n'est ni vraiment le
racisme on espère bien évidemment avoir
l'occasion par lightspeed de
sensibiliser nos élèves à d'autres types
de discriminations et à faire en sorte
que le vivre ensemble se diffuse le
mieux possible
plus de 2500 élèves seront ainsi
sensibilisés sur ces deux périodes
d'intervention
après deux années de recul les actes
antisémites ont augmenté de 74% en 2018
jusqu'au 26 décembre le danseur
yvelinois christophe ouest et sur la
scène de l'opéra bastille à paris pour
l'opéra à bâle et le prince igor
originaire de voisins-le-bretonneux il a
notamment évolué au sein de la compagnie
illicites
tous les vendredis il continue
d'ailleurs à y donner des cours
mélanie peau qu'elle a rencontrés dans
le cadre de notre dossier consacré aux
personnalités évinoise voici un petit
extrait j'ai commencé par par le hip hop
parce que c'était aussi ce que je voyais
de la danse qui me plaisait de par les
films de danse que je pouvais voir les
clips avec les artistes les concerts et
puis après plus il ya eu de travail dans
la danse et plus gc prendre d'autres
styles
bondues contemporain du classique
différents styles qui lui permettent de
multiplier les expériences
danse avec les stars auprès de shy'm
elle aussi formé à vichy dance les dix
commandements la comédie musicale
chorégraphié par kamel ouali ou encore
avec soprano pour la fête de la musique
le maquilleur qui coule fois le sujet
complet est à retrouver sur notre site
internet et des 78 points comme de la
danse encore avec le mythique ballet de
roméo et juliette qui sera sur la scène
du théâtre alexandre dumas de saint
germain en laye c'est avec la compagnie
et les fentes in the black box
ce sera le jeudi à 19 décembre à 20h45
[Musique]
vous
une visite spectacle de la galerie des
glaces et des grands appartements du
château de versailles c'est ce que vous
propose du 14 au 29 décembre le parcours
du roi un parcours en compagnie de
comédiens de danseurs et deux musiciens
baroques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
noël approche et la commanderie
d'elancourt vous propose de le célébrer
de manière décalée
au programme jusqu'au 19 décembre une
ferme ainsi qu'une grande vitrine de
noël
l'arbre à mot sur lequel vous pouvez
accrocher un mot une phrase ou encore un
poème
des concerts auront également lieu les
17 18 et 19 décembre
les compétences de la de la commanderie
c'est l'image que ça quand un dock c'est
l'innovation c'est la création
donc en fait c'est cette image qu'on
veut développer mais en gardant les
idées de la fête noël de relations
familiales
il y aura le 17 18 et 19 décembre
des chorales qui viendront chanter des
chants adapté donc de noël mais venant
aussi de tous les horizons et de tous
les styles de deux cultures
il y aura de l'humour le samedi 21
décembre à la lanterne à rambouillet sur
scène ben et arnaud tsamere dans un seul
et même spectacle
c'est à partir de 20h45 john quelles
sont les conséquences du bric site sur
le quotidien des britanniques ou à tahar
ouattar l'icône sequels ibrix ait fort
for the basic people in the life of all
the day
[Musique]
what du cinéma à présent c'est un film
attendu par des centaines de millions de
fans à travers le monde
le 18 décembre sort dans les salles
obscures star wars l'ascension de
skywalker
c'est le neuvième épisode il s'agit en
fait de la conclusion de la saga star
wars voici un extrait pour faire
patienter les jedi qui sont mes temps
[Musique]
c'était la peur
destin de toutes ces dames
destin
[Musique]
avant de se quitter comme chaque semaine
votre rendez vous ce soir on sera sans
compte en yvelines quatre idées de
sorties avec tout d'abord une version un
peu particulière de la pièce roméo et
juliette ce sera la ferme de bel ébat
des percussions et de la musique
électronique au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de l'humour
avec olivia moorea mounira qui seront
sur la scène de la salle jacques brel à
montigny le bretonneux et puis du jazz
au théâtre alphonse daudet à coignières
voici quelques extraits de cette
sélection c'est que nos conférences
spectacles
qu'ils essayent doit compter malgré tout
l'histoire de roméo juliette en se
permettant quelques détours aux
déviations vers d'autres oeuvres de
shakespeare comme tablette
macbeth le roi lear tantôt en expliquant
d'où viennent les heures ou temps on se
dissimulant par lui même les scènes de
roméo juliette et vous déménagez quant à
laure anne ont par contre je vais pas
venir vous aider non parce que c'est
chiant basse et c'est lourd c'est
salissant et moi j'ai horreur du bordel
bon coeur non mais ce qu'on fera c'est
que vous m'invitez à dîner quand vous
avez fini quoique enfin quand vous aurez
ranger et je vous offrirai une bouillie
voilà moi je vous lis le petit africain
que je parraine
il fait bien de rester au pays
d'ailleurs tous les étrangers sont bien
mieux chez eux
on n'a plus les moyens d'accueillir
toute la misère du monde
la france n'est pas la mâchoire de
didier deschamps
[Musique]
en vain
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour un numéro
spécial consacré aux temps forts de la
saison 1 2020
[Musique]